so we're going to talk about space
filling curves
so
already that sounds sort of
counter-intuitive like a curve is like a
one like it's a very skinny
one-dimensional thing but space is like
two-dimensional or something so how can
you have a curve that fills up
everything in space so we're going to
build a curve starting with something
very simple then we're going to sort of
change it so let's start
with
this curve here so this is three sides
of a square so at the moment this is
really not very space filling right it's
just three lines so we need to kind of
make it more squiggly and we'll get
there so let's let's draw a grid
on this so
like four squares
and so my curve is like going through
the centers of those squares
so what we're going to do to make this
red curve more squiggly
is
divide each of these squares into four
so like chop it up we want to make a
more squiggly version of this but we're
going to use the same shape
so here's how you do you sort of have to
rotate it a little bit to make it work
so
there's the the same shape but i've
rotated it
and then we'll do one like that
another one like that
and one like this
and then we need to connect them up so
let's connect them up like this
and like this
like this
and you can see this is
maybe slightly more space thing like
it's getting more places than than this
one was
and it's sort of made of the same stuff
so
well let's do another one why not and
then in each one of these squares i need
to put this thing here so let me
make a
a grid
and then i just have to turn things the
right way again so i want to take this
thing
and rotate it and put it here so it's
going to start like that
and it's going to end like that
and in the middle it's going to do this
and it's going to do this
and let's connect them up with red
because
okay so we've got that shape
and then this one over here
let's do this one next because it's easy
because it's just right this is the
reflection of this one connect them up
boop boop
and then these i'm getting good at this
now so this is going to be like that
connect up connect up connect up okay
and then again we connect up in the same
way we do across like that and like that
and like that
and we've got something that's
more squiggly more sort of space filling
and you can see how like you would just
continue doing this so so this is the
hilbert curve so this was invented by or
discovered by david hilbert in 1891.
really these are like steps in the
construction of it the hilbert curve is
when you do this infinitely many times
you're using a sharpie which has
thickness to it right but surely a
theoretical line has no thickness yes
zero thickness so if something has zero
thickness how can it feel any space well
right every step
the thing that you have has no thickness
is filling nothing but somehow when you
go infinitely far
well actually what happens is that
in a
rigorous way which i'm not going to get
into but actually what happens when you
go infinitely far
this curve hits every point of the
square
so somehow at the limit when you get
infinitely far boom you've got
everything this construction is not just
used for this sort of infinite thing
this is also
you know a way to sort of pack sort of
two-dimensional data
in a one-dimensional order right so
suppose you have a bunch of
two-dimensional data that you need to
store for some reason and you need to
store it in some linear order but you
also want this bit of data and this bit
of data they're quite close to each
other in two dimensions and you would
like them to be close to each other in
the ordering and the hilbit curve kind
of gives you a way of
often two points that are close together
in two dimensions are also close
together in the linear order right and
whereas if you did like you know just
sort of if you just ordered it by rows
then that's sort of less likely to be
true anyway so so it's it's important in
computer science i think there's even
some theories that the way that dna is
packed up when it's wrapped up in the
chromosome is sort of like this
but anyway so what i was interested in
was this sequence of of curves like the
the sequence of polygons how you get
there and so you can think of this like
as an animation going from one to the
next to the next and so on through time
or
you could think of this as
space rather than time so well so there
we go this is a 3d printed sculpture
that shows this construction at the very
top
you've got the original curve
and then
well so you can see there's like a band
here that's just a sort of intermediate
band but then the next band down so two
down is the next step of the sequence
it's probably a little hard to see
but it starts here and then it goes
across and then up and then back and
then it goes up and it does it does that
curve that we had before
and then
it just keeps going down so another two
steps and another two steps so so
there's the bottom that's that's quite
far along
in let's see how it's this is so the
first step second step third step this
is the fifth step of that sequence
and
i mean in principle i could just keep
going right
but it gets very thin and difficult to
print so this is one of many
space-filling curves or fractal curves
so
uh so there's one called the the dragon
curve
yeah oh right you did one on this lots
way more than you can fold a bit of
paper you get this rather stunning
pattern and it keeps going
but in the middle it gets very intricate
so how does the dragon curve one so
here's the first one you just have a
straight line
and then the next level down there's
just a like a right angle corner and
then the next one down this this one
every every band is another step of the
the dragon curve sequence and then at
the bottom you've got your your dragon
curve so this is like
one two three four five six
seven
eight
nine i think this is nine iterations of
the dragon curve
but right when you sort of extrude it
through space you get this this cooler
this cool shape somebody somebody wants
to describe this to me as a skyscraper
going for a walk
it's sort of a nice image recognize this
this shape that would be the uh sipinsky
triangle except there's a curve called
the
sipinski arrowhead curve
let's turn it around
so it starts with again this is smoothed
off a little bit but it starts with
three sides of a hexagon
and then
well it gets more squiggly
but yeah you end up with
the uh something that looks like the
sipinsky triangle i wanted to show you
the clone troopers
uh so
right so you'd make all this
like this is just math right i mean
there's just a simple sequence
but then once you've made it you you see
the faces
the eyes and the noses and the and the
mouth here
um at least i don't know maybe you've
blacked all blanked your mind of all
references of the prequels but clean
troopers is what this said to me so in
the other room there's one based on
something called the terdragon curve
it's like the dragon curve but there's a
three in it there's a slightly different
process that does it and yeah this is a
really big one that we died in a very
large trash can so final thing this is
sort of a three-dimensional version of
the two-dimensional hilbert curve so
this sort of three-dimensional versions
of a lot of these this is the third step
right so rather than showing the whole
sequence sort of as an extruded
animation
this is just the third step
of that sequence and you get this very
squiggly curve that is filling
three-dimensional space or
three-dimensional cube so one of the the
sort of really interesting things about
this is like so i i'd seen this thing
for like i don't know a year or two
sitting on my computer's screen as this
rigid perfect mathematical object and
then so you know i order it and i take
it out of the box and it's springy i had
no idea it was gonna do that it's it's
incredibly springy like you can use you
can even
wear it as a kind of uncomfortable
bracelet
um but yeah this
well you can see that it's a curve right
it's just a single loop in space
that forms itself back into a cube
and you were surprised by that yeah no
like i mean i guess i could have
predicted it maybe that because it's
just you know there's no
interconnections so it's just this sort
of like single loop it should be
flexible but i just never thought of it
that way
and then it was you know having the
physical thing there's i mean what you
can you can't not notice that it's all
springy
if you enjoy henry's videos here on
numberphile then you're really going to
love his new book about visualizing
mathematics with 3d printing i'll put
some information about it in the video
description and while you're in the
video description why not check out the
list of people who support us on patreon
our thanks to them for helping out but
seriously check out that book it's got
some mind-blowing stuff in it and it's
also a really good way to show your
support for henry who helps us out here
on number five